all right I guess I'll watch one more
movie
[Music]
trick-or-treating I want candy
why do you do this I've literally never
seen you eat candy on Halloween or ever
but I love Halloween please Quinn just
this once no I've got stuff to do I'm
working on a video about aliens I don't
have time to take you trick-or-treating
even if I wanted to wait you're making a
video about me no not you scary aliens
what am I supposed to do it's Halloween
I don't know go play video games or
something use my PC fine I'm going
upstairs to play The Sims now let's see
where was I ah yes I love aliens there's
something about the thought of
extraterrestrials that's just
captivating to me I've always loved
science fiction so aliens were a big
part of my childhood E.T Close
Encounters of the Third Kind the idea
that aliens could exist and that they
could have this incredible technology
that would allow them to travel the
stars and leap between galaxies made me
believe that anything was possible maybe
one day Humanity could join in in the
dance of cosmic civilization but then
there's the other side of the coin too
yes the thought of a universe bustling
with fantastic life and fantastic
technology is exciting it's also scary
too not every alien would be friendly
like E.T maybe they wouldn't come and
simply play music notes like the aliens
in Close Encounters
what about the Body Snatchers what about
Ripley's Xenomorph the dark and twisted
forms of the lovecraftian Mythos
aliens might not be our friends the Dark
Side of extraterrestrials has been
explored in books movies and TV shows
for decades now stories of alien
encounters and abductions have
captivated our minds for years and years
but what makes aliens so scary to
understand this we have to dive into the
history of aliens in science fiction and
the true historical events that inspired
some of these stories we'll also discuss
some of my favorite horrifying
depictions of aliens and books movies
and TV shows all in all we're in for a
pretty spooky evening it's time for the
second ever Quinn's ideas Halloween
special
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
though the giant bodies in outer space
that we would eventually call galaxies
were originally discovered by French
astronomer Charles Messier in the 17th
century Edwin Hubble in 1923 was the
first to realize what they actually were
it turned out that there were actually
countless galaxies in our universe made
up of billions upon billions of stars
and trillions of planets it did not take
humans long at all to do what we do best
imagine if there were trillions of
planets throughout the vastness of space
could there be another world like ours
with sentient beings like us from that
point onward we begin to see aliens
everywhere first let's talk about one of
the most iconic if not the most iconic
alien moment in United States history
and to set things up I'm gonna quote one
of my favorite lines from the book God
emperor of Dune by Frank Herbert
we are myth Killers you and I maneo that
is the dream we share I assure you from
a God's Olympian perch that government
is a shared myth when the myth dies the
government dies a government can only
function if it can continue to justify
its hierarchy in the minds of the
populace there will always be some
mistrust between citizens and
governments but really bad things happen
when people lose faith in their
government entirely the Roswell crash
has captivated the minds of Believers
for decades and become an obsession for
some largely because being mistrustful
of the government seems to be society's
natural state
it is easy for people to believe that
the government could and would cover up
something something like an alien ship
crash if it happened the Roswell
incident is one of my favorite stories
slash American Legends now most people
definitely most Americans have heard the
story of the Roswell crash but in case
you haven't I'll reiterate in 1947 in
the deserts of New Mexico an object
crashed from the sky
more than 30 years later in 1980 Charles
berlitz and William L Moore published
the Roswell incident according to this
book an alien craft had been flying over
the desert of New Mexico observing
nuclear bomb testing activity by the way
lots of alien experts I guess claim that
it was in fact nuclear bombs that
alerted the alien life forms to our
presence on Earth or at least increased
already ongoing monitoring of the planet
anyway this alien ship was supposedly
hit by lightning according to the
Roswell incident this caused the vessel
to crash killing the extraterrestrials
on board the United States government
would then go on to cover up the actual
event
the official government story of what
actually went down in Roswell states
that the crash was no more than a mere
weather balloon accident so maybe that
explains it except it kind of doesn't
there are some things about this story
that are just plain weird now the
Roswell incident was not the first
flying saucer story Americans ever heard
in fact several incidents had been
reported nationally just that summer
what made this different however is this
was the first reported crash of such an
object and the first account of a flying
saucer confirmed by a government
organization the next day following the
report of the crash the Roswell Army
Airfield the raaf released the following
statement
the many rumors regarding the flying
disc became a reality yesterday when the
intelligence office of the 509th bomb
group of the Eighth Air Force Roswell
Army Airfield was fortunate enough to
gain possession of a disc through the
cooperation of one of the local ranchers
and the Sheriff's Office of Chaves
County the statement also states that a
man named Major Jesse Marshall was the
intelligence officer who oversaw the
investigation of the crash site the
statement very clearly confirms that
what they had recovered was some sort of
flying disc not a weather balloon right
hmm let's dig deeper the next day
following a story detailing the crash by
the Roswell daily the United States Army
changed their story they retracted the
statement that they had recovered a
flying disc and instead stated that they
had found the debris of a weather
balloon the next day the Roswell daily
ran a story which featured a photograph
of major Marcel posing with pieces of
what appeared to be weather balloon
debris of course many did not believe
this story and the lack of government
transparency did not help this story
stoked conspiracy theories and suspicion
for years until finally in 1994 the U.S
Air Force admitted that the weather
balloon story had been in fact faked
here the government claimed that the
object had actually been a highly
classified spy device the object was
supposedly connected to a string of high
altitude balloons equipped with
microphones according to the 1994 report
they had been intended to float over the
USSR now the description of this
technology doesn't exactly sound like a
flying disc and then there are also the
reports that bodies were removed from
the crash in 1997 the United States
government released a statement denying
the rumor that bodies had been recovered
from the crash site instead they claimed
that the so-called bodies were in fact
test dummies rather than the corpses of
alien life forms
I think there is a clear reason that the
Roswell story has been so captivating
over the years the thought of a
conspiracy is compelling and when the
government completely lacks transparency
and often changes their story it only
adds fuel to the fire and why does the
United States government keep addressing
this story at all I mean was there
really a need to bring up the story
again and change details 50 years later
but no matter what you believe about the
Roswell incident you can't deny that it
did stoke the UFO phenomenon and it also
became the inspiration for an insane
amount of awesome science fiction
stories some of which we'll go into in
just a little bit the end of the 1960s
would bring another event that would
again Stoke interest in
extraterrestrials however the moon
landing unlike the localized Roswell
incident would be reported on and
watched globally Apollo 11 was launched
by the Saturn V rocket from Florida
sending three astronauts Commander Neil
Armstrong Michael Collins and Buzz
Aldrin further into outer space than any
humans had ever been Aldrin unlike
Armstrong and Collins never actually
landed on the surface of the Moon
instead he piloted the moon module in
lunar orbit while the other two explored
the surface
you might have heard the rumor that Buzz
Aldrin actually saw a UFO whilst
piloting though this claim may be
technically true UFO doesn't mean alien
spaceship necessarily and Aldrin later
confirmed that he was 99 sure the object
had merely been a detached adapter panel
from the spacecraft so that solves that
unless the government forced him to lie
about it like in Roswell speaking of
government conspiracies I know there's a
portion of people out there that don't
believe the moon landing was real but
guys honestly we can see the flag it
happened okay but whether or not it did
Mankind's landing on the moon was a
giant moment for science fiction if we
can land on the moon in the real world
what amazing things can we do in the
fictional World perhaps travel to other
planets planets that might be inhabited
if you ask most people well my audience
at least if they believe in aliens most
people would say yes aliens almost
certainly exist somewhere out there in
the universe but the likelihood that
they have visited us is Slim that
however doesn't change the fact that
some people firmly believe that aliens
have visited us incidents of UFO
sightings have become relatively common
in the last century or so people report
unidentified flying objects all the time
the vast majority of cases of course can
be dismissed but there are a few that
simply defy explanation we simply don't
know one of these examples is the aerial
School UFO incident 60 school children
in Zimbabwe aged 6 to 12 claim to have
seen alien spacecraft's land the robed
in Black figures supposedly communicated
an environmental message those kids are
adults today and those that speak out
publicly still have the same story now
you could chalk this all up to mass
hysteria or faults of memory but the
truth is as I said we just don't know
what we do know is that we as a society
are obsessed with the idea that aliens
are here watching over us maybe they are
benevolent here to help us in some way
maybe they are here for a different
reason maybe all of this is yet again
the result of Mankind's incredible
imagination
either way the same is true for me as it
was when I was a kid whether or not
aliens are here whether or not they even
exist
I want to believe
more than anything I really do think it
is fear that makes the thought of aliens
compelling to us as the world becomes
more connected more the same true
alienness becomes harder and harder to
encounter it becomes more rare so we
look to the stars and project our fear
of the other onto the ultimate other the
Extraterrestrial
[Music]
whoa
what the heck was that
I'll be right back guys
hello
is anyone out here
is anyone out here
[Music]
ah
[Applause]
[Music]
where am I
[Music]
okay that was weird anyway let's move on
with the video so why are aliens scary
there are several reasons that I can
point to
it has been said that the oldest fear is
the fear of the unknown the fear of the
unknown stands at the root of some of
our greatest horror stories Infamous but
brilliant writer H.P Lovecraft has
influenced the entire horror genre his
work speaks because it reflects his
genuine fear of the unknown and of the
other the fear of the other is at the
root of our fear of aliens aliens are
scary because we don't know them we
can't predict their behavior they could
be cruel they could see us as bugs
beneath them they could enslave us steal
our world's resources and then discard
us they could in essence do to us what
we do to each other or perhaps even
worse infinite Terrors await within the
unknown WE peer into the darkness of
space and yet we do not know what might
be peering back or what it might be
capable of the fear of colonization is
at the root of what is likely the most
famous Trope in science fiction the
Alien Invasion now this Motif has been
around since the 1800s in fact H.G Wells
wrote War of the Worlds the most famous
Alien Invasion story of all time in 1898
but the concept really took off in the
1950s and especially the 1960s following
the start of the Cold War tons of Alien
Invasion movies were released around
this time Freddie francis's They Came
From Beyond Terence Fisher's the Earth
dies screaming Steve sekele's the day of
the tri-fids Don Siegel's Invasion of
the Body Snatcher Maury Dexter's the day
Mars invaded Earth the list goes on
indefinitely and it wasn't just movies
tons of books too trust me
basically we've seen throughout history
time and time again how things usually
go when a technologically Superior Group
encounters a less developed civilization
usually the less developed civilization
is far worse off in the end if not
completely destroyed often they lose
agency and any claim to ancestral land
that should be rightfully theirs humans
can't help but project these ideas onto
a potentially technologically Superior
Advanced extraterrestrial race if this
is how it goes most of the time on Earth
why would interaction between species of
different worlds be any different life
after all is a competition of resources
and there are finite resources in the
universe what would drive a species to
expend the incredible amount of
resources and energy that would be
required to travel great distances of
space if not the desire to acquire more
resources though this of course isn't
necessarily the case this is a big part
of what keeps this fear in Our Minds
when we think about intelligent
space-faring alien life another Motif in
science fiction which seems to have
gained traction around the late 1950s
features the reproductive capabilities
of women as the target of Alien Invaders
the aliens want to breed with us to
taint our genes with their hideous
foreign DNA the root fear here is of
course xenophobia if you look at
Geiger's creation for Ridley Scott's
film Alien the creatures literally
called the xenomorph Xeno equals
different and morph to undergo change
and if you haven't seen alien spoiler
alert the xenomorph forcefully
impregnates its host in order to
reproduce
now listen to me carefully here because
I'm obviously not saying that everyone
that has a fear of being impregnated by
an extraterrestrial is xenophobic
towards foreigners in fact I'd argue
that the vast majority are not however
when we examine the history of this
Motif we see pretty clearly what the
root fear is the Trope gained Traction
in the 1950s and 60s at a time when the
United States was going through a period
of immense change the Civil Rights
Movement was in full swing different
races of people were beginning to mix
and mingle more and more which was a
great thing but also of course a lot of
people didn't like this this caused a
lot of let's say anxiety for some people
that anxiety I think manifested itself
in the media of the time in one way as
the aliens want our women Trope nowadays
of course aliens breeding with humans is
just a staple of the genre the root of
the motif however la like the root of
many things is a bit dark examples of
this Motif include
1958's film I married a monster from
outer space
in this movie grotesque male aliens
masquerade in the form of human men in
order to impregnate women they flee from
earth once their breeding plan is
exposed there's also a 1960s Village of
the Damned and in 1981s and siminoid
and of course also tons of books which
use this Trope women being impregnated
by alien life forms has historically
been an extremely common theme
especially in science fiction films
interestingly enough in the 1990s we
really saw a kind of reversal of this
Trope one example who we will talk about
more later is Sil from the movie Species
Sil is a female alien who essentially
requires the DNA of human men in order
to breed so it's a flip because no
longer is the woman a damsel that must
be saved from the terrifying space Man
From Another World but instead she is
the alien Terror herself and all men
despair
there is also an aspect of this Trope
that has to do with alien beings
altering our biology in such a way that
it brings into question what it even
means to be human
Octavia Butler deals with this concept
in her xenogenesis Trilogy in which the
alien life forms known as the Owen Kali
seek to merge their DNA with that of
humanities
the main takeaway from all this is that
we are the aliens and no I don't mean it
like that although maybe but what I
really mean is that our fears of aliens
reflect who we are aliens are scary to
us because we project the bad side of
humanity onto them
all the things that we fear from aliens
are things that human beings have
already done and are doing to each other
there's one Final Fear I want to talk
about before we talk about some of the
creepiest aliens in science fiction
I've heard it often said that the
thought of humanity being alone in the
universe is existentially terrifying but
funny enough the idea that we are not
alone can be equally scary to some some
religions for instance believe that
humans are God's Soul Children created
in His image if aliens exist it puts
into question various religious texts
that do not account for other sentient
civilizations from beyond the stars if
we are alone we are all that is if we
are not then that means that one day we
might have to face what else is out
there
For Better or For Worse
so now that we've talked about that we
can get on to
wait
where did this
flower pot come from wasn't in my set
wait a second
these aren't my clothes
what
what is going on right now I'll be right
back guys
what the hell
okay that's better that was super weird
don't know what the deal with that was
but anyway moving on so now that we've
gone over what makes the general concept
of alien scary it's time to talk about
some of my favorite books depicting
scary aliens
[Applause]
so now that we've gone over what makes
the general concept of alien scary let's
discuss some of my favorite books
depicting scary aliens now keep in mind
these are just my opinions and there are
tons of alien books so I couldn't
mention everything list your favorites
in the comment section below
we can't talk about terrifying aliens
without talking about the most famous
Alien Invasion story of all time now
we've discussed this book before on this
channel particularly in my video the
first aliens but in this video we're
going to focus on something slightly
different than just the themes and The
Narrative of the book instead we will
talk about the book's cultural impact HG
wells's War of the Worlds was first
published in book form in 1898 the story
which was first serialized in a magazine
was initially successful but gained new
cultural relevance in the United States
when Orson welles's radio show the
Mercury Theater on the air aired a
special Halloween episode featuring the
story the broadcast is famous because
apparently some people that were
listening didn't realize that they were
hearing a radio drama broadcast instead
some people became convinced that
martians were actually invading the
Earth you see the first two-thirds of
the broadcast were presented as a series
of news bulletins which caused some
listener to panic now though it's
basically been proven that newspapers at
the time over exaggerated the size of
the Panic it's undeniable that H.G
wells's story got a boost in popularity
following the event
the first movie adaptation would appear
in 1953 and since then there have been
countless adaptations and parodies of
H.E wells's classic story what's scary
about the Martians in this story is that
as we would study a tiny microbe in a
Petri dish they studied us and waited
for just the right moment to strike
HP Lovecraft is one of the most
influential horror authors of all time
my last Halloween special was entirely
dedicated to breaking down his most
famous story The Call of Cthulhu here
we're going to talk about another of
lovecraft's monstrous creations azathoth
outside the ordered universe is that
amorphous blight of nethermost confusion
which blasphemes and Bubbles at the
center of all Infinity
the boundless demon Sultan azathoth
whose name no lips dare speak aloud and
who gnaws hungrily in inconceivable
unlighted Chambers Beyond time and space
amidst the muffled maddening beating of
vile drums and the thin monotonous wine
of accursed flutes
the dream quest of unknown kadath
azathoth is a monstrous being at the
center of the Galaxy he is the Supreme
entity more powerful than any others in
lovecraft's Mythos he has many names the
blind dreamer nuclear chaos the deep
dark the blind idiot God the primordial
dimmy urge but most simply he is the
Supreme Lord and creator of all things
azathoth has no definite form or at
least those who Envision him see him in
various forms as a thought is scary
because many people wonder if there is a
God an omnipodent Creator in charge of
all things people tend to assume that if
such a God exists it would have our best
interest in mind or at least it would be
concerned with us to some degree but
realistically if we'd look at the chaos
of the world the chaos of the universe
does any of it really suggest that one
terrifying possibility if God does exist
is that God is an immense entity of
cosmic chaos and darkness terrible to
behold an entity whose name itself
should not be spoken an alien
monstrosity of mindless Eternal horror
ancient legends of ultimate chaos at
whose Center sprawls the blind idiot God
as a thought Lord of All Things
encircled by his flopping horde of
mindless and amorphous dancers and
lulled by the thin monotonous piping of
a demonic flute held in nameless paws
the Haunter in the dark
now let's talk about the scramblers from
Peter Watts blind sight I've actually
done a couple videos on this channel
going into this novel and you can check
those out Linked In the description long
story short the scramblers are
non-sentient intelligent race of beings
they may have had actual Consciousness
at some point in their evolution and
eventually grew beyond the need of it
either way the spooky thing about them
and other aliens like them depicted in
science fiction is what they imply about
us Consciousness and self-awareness
wasn't a necessity for the scramblers to
gain space travel it was not a necessity
for them to learn to communicate with us
with seeming comprehension
it all kind of implies that maybe human
consciousness is a fluke maybe sapience
is not really necessary maybe it's even
a hindrance
I think that the idea of this is
particularly terrifying today because in
a lot of ways it does kind of feel like
humanity is devolving in intelligence we
are thinking for ourselves less and less
and becoming more dependent on Computing
machines to do our mental labor you know
in a lot of ways that's the way Humanity
has always been if there is a crutch to
lean on we will lean on it it is very
easy for people not to think for
themselves and just to choose to go
along with the crowd and become just
another non-thinking member of The Horde
so we have to talk about the
trisolareans from Shin Luz remembrance
of Earth's past Trilogy the trisolarins
mainly represent the fear of a
technologically advanced civilization
which is able to subjugate and
annihilate Humanity through their vastly
Superior technology the trisolarins
themselves aren't scary in the
traditional sins and Humanity never
physically interacts with the
trisolarians at any point during the war
and yet trisolarin technology is able to
[ __ ] Earth technological growth and
Destroy Earth's entire space force
before any trisolarian individual ever
gets close to our solar system I've done
an entire series on the three body
problem series and the trisolarin so if
you want to learn more about that click
on the playlist in the description the
Glimpse we get of the trisolarin
civilization and the first book shows us
that their society is devoid of
individuality art and love it is a
society that exists only to survive and
to serve the greater Society this aspect
of trisolare in society is spooky
because it warns of what Humanity could
potentially be in the real world
humanity is defined by the things the
trisolerance lack it is the same reason
that the Borg and Star Trek are scary
but don't worry we'll get to Star Trek
later on
next up is lock and key so if you've
seen Netflix's version of this graphic
novel forget about it throw it away Zip
Zap it's gone it doesn't exist it never
existed in all seriousness though if you
love that show more power to you but the
book the book Joe Hill has been writing
some of the best horror stories for
years now there's Nosferatu the black
phone I really love the cape one and two
I thought they were really fun and dark
and twisted Joe Hill is doing some
really great things and because he is
the son of probably the greatest horror
author of all time Stephen King he seems
to be somewhat a fan of the work of H.P
Lovecraft and it shows spoilers ahead
essentially in lock and key there is a
door though it doesn't always look like
a door it is deep within a cave near the
ocean the things that wait on the other
side of the door desperately want the
door to be opened they will spur from
the other side at some point a lock was
created a lock forged from a strange
metal which had come through the other
side of the door it was the only thing
that could hold the door closed and the
Omega key also forged from the same
Meadow is the only thing that can open
the lock
the creatures on the other side can only
exist in our world if they have flesh to
inhabit so in order to live they must
still the body of a human
now the interesting thing is one of
these creatures is free and it
desperately wants to open the door but
first it has to get the keys from the
keepers of the keys it's plural because
there are actually a lot more keys in
the story than just the Omega key
and they all do various things there's a
lot to the story actually what makes
this particular aspect of the story
scary is that there is a door to another
place a door which can be relatively
easily opened and if it is opened an
unspeakable Darkness will enter our
world and inhabit our skin
I know what you're saying Quinn this
really isn't an alien story I know but
it is lovecraftian and if we're talking
about interdimensionality then what
really is the fundamental difference
between extraterrestrials of our own
physical Dimension and beings From
Another Dimension Stephen King like his
son Joe Hill obviously grew up reading
the work of Lovecraft in his book it he
creates one of the scariest lovecraftian
beings to ever appear on paper the
creature referred to throughout the
novel only by the pronoun it
spoilers ahead we learn about two-thirds
of the way through the novel that this
creature came to Earth from Beyond outer
space a place called The macroverse
basically the greater universe that our
universe is merely a speck within this
creature and another creature which was
its opposite called the turtle were
alive before the beginning of the
universe the turtle was a creature of
life and creation it was a being of
malevolence and consumption during the
vast eons of its early existence it fed
upon the petty forms within the
macroverse but eventually it wanted
better food so it came to Earth millions
of years before mankind ever even
existed and it waited it waited beneath
the place that would eventually become
the town of Derry its killing pin it
waited for Humanity because unlike the
petty forms of the macroverse or the
lower animals of Earth human beings
could truly dream with our imaginations
we can conjure up visions of the
greatest pleasure and the greatest
terrors
it had come here long after the turtle
withdrew into its shell here to Earth
and it discovered a depth of imagination
here that was almost new almost of
concern this quality of imagination made
the food very rich its teeth-rit flesh
gone stiff with exotic Terrors and
voluptuous fears they dreamed of night
beast and moving muds against their will
they contemplated endless Gulfs
once Humanity came along this creature
existed in a constant cycle of waking to
feed upon the fear and flesh of mankind
and then returning to a dreaming state
only to awaken later and start the cycle
again what makes this creature so
terrifying is that it can read your
thoughts and determine what scares you
the most when it feeds it acts as a
reflector of your greatest fears one of
the things that makes this creature
truly monstrous is that it chooses to
feed on children simply because it's
easier to do so
children unlike adults have very simple
fears the monster under the bed the
vampire outside the window the swamp
monster under the lake adulthood fears
are more complicated it's easier to
transform into a werewolf than to kill
someone with the fear of missing their
mortgage payment or something
what I really like about this book is
how the malevolence of this creature
driven by only the desire to consume to
satiate its own Pleasures affects the
town of dairy everyone who lives there
knows that there is something wrong with
dairy but they choose to turn away from
it because it is easier to turn away
from the Unspeakable evils which are
occurring all around you than it is to
stand up to it this evil is powerful
Beyond Comprehension and no one person
could ever hope to stand against it
alone
that was part of how it was able to keep
killing for so long
Stephen King also has a couple of other
interesting books that depict pretty
creepy aliens like the Tommy knockers
and also dreamcatcher and coincidentally
the main four characters in that book
were raised in the town of Derry
sometime after it was supposedly
banished because Stephen King has a
really cool shared Universe in his books
and I really enjoy that sort of thing
okay honorable mentions as far as books
go the overlords from Arthur C Clarke's
childhood's end I also covered this book
in my video the first aliens the aliens
in this one look like literal demons so
you know spooky
foreign
[Applause]
okay it's time to talk about Star Trek
I don't know if I've ever said this but
I love Star Trek Star Trek the Next
Generation was my first love but I also
really enjoyed Deep Space Nine and
Voyager and recently strange new worlds
Star Trek has some of the most beloved
characters ever created but it also
isn't short of creepy entities let's
start by discussing one of the most
unsettling episodes of Star Trek the
Next Generation season twos where
Silence has lease
in this episode the crew of the
Enterprise encounter an area in space
that is totally black no stars no light
just nothing
being that the Enterprise crew is on an
exploratory Mission they choose to enter
the void only to afterwards find out
that they cannot Escape after a bunch of
really eerie and strange Shenanigans the
creature tormenting them finally shows
itself
it is an alien entity known as nagilum
it is essentially all-powerful in this
region of space it attempts to take a
human form but appears as an uncanny
distorted face like some mad scientist
it performs experiments on the
Enterprise crew even brutally killing a
member of the bridge crew in Cold Blood
In order to observe death
the creature then announces that it will
kill about a third of the crew in
various ways in order to test all of the
manners in which humans can die
it is up to Captain Picard to thwart
this entity which sees humans as no more
than fodder for its experiments this is
one of my favorite episodes of Star Trek
the Next Generation and this was before
the show got officially good in many
people's eyes I personally think nagilum
is one of the creepiest alien beings to
ever appear in the Star Trek universe
and they should totally bring him back
in a newer episode in the series now
that we have like four different Star
Trek shows happening now if nagilum
doesn't do it for you let's talk about
another of the creepiest alien
adversaries to ever appear in Star Trek
the Borg so most people probably know
about the Borg the Borg first appear in
the Next Generation episode Q who q and
essentially all powerful alien life form
manages to thrust the Enterprise further
into their Galaxy than mankind has ever
traveled somewhere out there in the
darkness of space they encounter for the
first time the Borg the Borg aren't even
entirely composed of one specific
species in fact many different
biological species make up the Borg this
is because for many thousands of years
the Borg have been assimilating any new
species and technologies that they could
make useful to themselves the Borg are
hive-minded unrelenting the Borg are all
about sameness and conforming they
reject individuality all of these are
antithetical to the values of the
Federation
the Borg by far are the greatest
adversaries the Federation ever
encountered their conflict spans across
several Star Trek shows and at least one
movie honestly there are so many scary
aliens in Star Trek so many scary alien
episodes just the Next Generation alone
there's the episode where Lieutenant
Barkley is afraid of the transporter
which why wouldn't you be because it
literally takes her atoms apart and
re-materializes you somewhere else how
can you even be sure that your
Consciousness is even regenerated and
that that is the same Consciousness and
not just a clone of your Consciousness
which was dematerialized and thus
destroyed it opens up a whole can of
worms but anyway Barkley is the only one
that realizes that there's a monstrous
alien in the transporter there's also
the episode Clues where the crew loses
their memory in a strange region of
space and they have to uncover that
mystery and there is one truly
terrifying episode where the Android
data is having waking dreams and well
there's no spooky alien in this episode
but there is this scene
don't no no
you know what just watch Star Trek the
Next Generation if you haven't seen it
it's my favorite show of all time and
honestly it's just great and thoughtful
and the cast is so amazing and they have
so much chemistry there's some Bad
episodes especially in the first two
seasons but the cast more than makes up
for it whenever I need to deal with like
a huge moral quandary I just think wwpd
what would Picard do and it works every
time okay so since we're getting
extremely nerdy now we might as well
talk about Doctor Who if you asked a
doctor who fan what the scariest alien
creature was from the entire show I
think most people would either say the
silence or the Weeping Angels yes both
of those are insanely terrifying but
we're not gonna focus on them instead
we're gonna focus on what I honestly
think might be the creepiest Doctor Who
episode of all season 4's midnight this
episode's scared at the ball falls off
of me so in this episode the doctor is
visiting a resort on a crystalline
Planet there is a train that does a tour
of the world and the doctor decides to
take the tour
something happens however deep in the
crystalline Plains of the world the
train breaks down and something from the
outside world which should be toxic to
all life enters the Train the creature
whatever it is never shows a form of its
own it jumps into a woman aboard the
train and uses her to mimic and
eventually learn their language
it somehow affects the humans aboard the
train through suggestion it makes them
paranoid and angry with each other
eventually they even turn on the Doctor
Who is the only one who sees this
creature for what it really is something
terrible and forgotten that waited out
there in the crystalline Abyss had
attempted to catch a ride with them so
to speak this is without a doubt one of
the creepiest episodes of Doctor Who 10
out of 10 would recommend
all right so we can't really talk about
scary aliens and TV shows without
talking about the X-Files I love the
X-Files for all its plot holes and
narratives that go nowhere I really do
think that the X-Files like a lot of
shows from that era suffers early on
especially from the lack of
consideration to continuity and the lack
of connectivity between narratives that
we've come to expect from Modern shows I
really enjoy the X-Files though and even
though I haven't seen it as much as
Doctor Who and Star Trek The X-Files
absolutely shaped my taste in creepy
aliens growing up and if you're a fan of
Science Fiction it's likely that you've
been influenced by this show without
even realizing it because it gets
referenced everywhere
okay now let's get to some scary alien
movies that I like now again keep in
mind these are just my opinions also I
can't include every alien flick in this
video but anyway without further Ado
let's start off with John Carpenter's
they live
they live is a fantastic movie the thing
is however you gotta get through the
first 30 minutes of it and then trust me
it's worth it John Carpenter lulls you
into a false sense of familiarity with
this film you think I'm just watching
some cheesy 80s movie and yes yes you
are but there's so many more layers to
it spoiler alert if you haven't seen the
movie because I'm basically about to
spoil everything here skip ahead about
three minutes if you don't want to hear
any spoilers in Carpenter's film they
live our protagonist discovers that
aliens have actually taken over the
Earth but he only realizes this to be
the truth after he puts on special
glasses that reveal it to him these
glasses also reveal that all of our
advertisements and TV are really just
subliminal messages meant to keep us
docile and complacent what's great about
this is that for the first 30 minutes or
so the score is just this weird
hokey Noir Melody that just repeats over
and over again and that somehow totally
disarms you and when he puts on the
glasses it goes entirely silent
and it's horrifying
this movie kind of works for the same
reason that the Matrix works a lot of us
have the sense that there is a secret
world underneath the world that there
are Sinister intentions lurking behind
every corner a grand conspiracy that we
could Glimpse if only we could just
focus the lens of our perception
properly
the xenomorph from Ridley Scott's alien
is without a doubt one of the scariest
alien beings ever put on screen this
creature came straight out of the mind
of HR Giger whose dark and twisted
creations were rivaled by no other
everyone knows about the xenomorph but
as promised we're going to talk about
one of giger's lesser-known Creations
one which arguably was more dear to him
than the xenomorph I'm talking of course
about sill from 1999 species betcha
didn't see that coming well you probably
did since I mentioned it earlier species
is a film about scientists who receive a
signal from outer space it is from an
alien race of beings the signal contains
the genetic information of aliens and
details on how to combine it with our
own DNA the scientists believing that
they could contain the creation allowed
the experiment to go forward creating
sill however once sill reaches
Adolescence in a shockingly short period
of time the decision is made terminate
the project but before she can be killed
sill escapes on her own she pupates into
a fully grown woman and then the
breeding Drive is activated sill
desperately wants to mate but you know
it's kind of hard to find a good man
who's a match for you when you're an
ultra intelligent apex predator from
another world
from all the stories that I've heard
Giger was absolutely in love with this
character design and concept he even
spent his own money to create the scene
in the movie with the alien monster
train when the studio wouldn't pay for
it sill was designed to be sexually
provocative and terrifying at the same
time she was the embodiment of the
mixture of horror and sexuality that was
definitive of so much of kiger's work
what makes Sills scary is that she looks
like a woman most of the time but in
actuality she is a biological weapon she
was sent to Earth to breathe her
children would breed and eventually the
biologically Superior aliens would
dominate the Earth Humanity would be
replaced now of course the movie itself
has flaws and definitely not everything
in it is completely original it borrows
heavily from movies like the thing and
of course alien it's still pretty fun to
watch regardless and the concept when
you extract rapidly just a little bit is
terrifying there's something about the
way the aliens are depicted in signs
that is still horrifying to me they
radiate malice and there is a Sinister
Veil that drapes this entire film
because of it so if you haven't seen
signs then what are you doing go watch
signs seriously in case you don't know
signs is a movie about a family on a
farm who have crop circles start to
appear in their fields over time the
family and the world come to realize
that the planet is in fact being invaded
by malicious alien life forms what I
really like about this movie is though
you get the sense that the invasion is
occurring everywhere and that Society is
kind of falling apart the focus remains
on just one family so we really get to
develop these characters and develop a
really interesting family Dynamic so you
really root for their survival in this
movie also I feel like science has a
very satisfying ending some movies take
you on a good good ride but then the
ending kind of sucks here is not the
case this was the height of M Night
Shyamalan and this film does not
disappoint
the thing is of course another classic
science fiction alien I know two John
Carpenter films on the list I just
wanted to space things out a little bit
the alien monster in the thing is one of
the most terrifying creatures to ever be
featured in a science fiction movie
period what makes the thing so creepy is
the fact that it doesn't really have a
form of its own it needs a host to
infect and imitate it's more of a virus
than a monster really part of what's
really creepy about the thing and part
of what helps the movie itself be creepy
is the paranoia that occurs when we as
the audience as well as the characters
in the story realize that the thing
could be anyone at any given time it has
the ability to perfectly imitate a human
or any organism really the thing could
be your best friend and you would never
know also the dog transformation scene
has stuck with me for years
so yeah if you haven't seen the thing
watch it do not watch the 2011 prequel
because it is terrible
so the movie life is in a way almost a
spiritual successor to the thing
I mean the creature doesn't masquerade
in the form of a person but it shares
the similarity of being an almost
Unstoppable biological weapon so in
space these scientists encounter a
strange never before seen life form they
name it Calvin Calvin then proceeds to
kill them all we know this story we've
all seen alien but what I like about
this movie is that eventually the
characters just realize that they can't
even really do anything about it all
they can really do is attempt to keep
the creature whatever this life form is
from reaching Earth because obviously
this is an apex predator and Humanity
cannot coexist with it definitely give
the movie Life a try if you haven't
watched it also Rebecca Ferguson who
plays the lady Jessica in Dune is one of
the main characters and she's pretty
good in this the film Fire in the Sky is
supposedly based upon a true alien
abduction story whether that's true or
not is beyond the point I think it's
safe to say that Fire in the Sky
definitely gave many people abduction
nightmares even if they were never
actually abducted themselves because I
know it gave me nightmares I don't think
I've seen an alien abduction scene as
frightening as the one in Fire in the
Sky So Fire in the Sky is about these
friends that were out at night and one
of them gets abducted they all report
seeing it and there is no evidence of
Foul Play well the big twist is the
friend actually ends up showing again
and his description of the alien
abduction is so freaky and the way they
handle this scene in the movie is so
creepy and so freakish it will send
shivers down your spine Fire in the Sky
is a bit of a slow burn but it's
definitely worth it just for the alien
examination scene in my opinion all
right so last but not least the faculty
so one of my favorite Alien movies as a
kid was the faculty and if you haven't
seen the faculty just do yourself a
favor and watch it it's great it's
essentially a retelling of Invasion of
the Body Snatchers that takes place in a
high school in the 90s where the
teachers and eventually the students are
slowly being replaced by aliens from
another planet the creature design in
this movie is so interesting and grossly
freakish and the cast here is amazing
Elijah Wood before Lord of the Rings Jon
Stewart randomly plays the science
teacher we've got Piper Laurie from the
original adaptation of Stephen King's
carry we've got Famke Janssen from X-Men
and that one episode of Star Trek TNG
and we've even got a shirt making an
appearance here what I really like about
this film is it's just fun and it's
really exciting watching it for the
first time because you really get to
play that guessing game of who is the
alien it could be anybody and also this
scene
foreign
so the point of all this is aliens are
freaky the idea of being alone in the
universe and the idea of not being alone
are equally terrifying imagining an
alien race with Superior technology and
biology to our own is frightening
because in their position we know how we
as a species would react and also the
idea of aliens causing changes to our
biology is scary because it brings into
question what it even means to be human
in the first place we would all like to
have the optimistic view of aliens and
maybe we will get the luck of the draw
and the first alien life we encounter
will be akin to the Vulcans from Star
Trek and instead of subjugating us and
draining our planet of resources they
will induct us into a kind of Federation
of planets I Can Dream can't I either
way I think alien life will always be
kind of scary to us even if we did
encounter a friendly race of alien
beings that were aren't hostile would we
even be able to trust them humans don't
even trust each other
and I think that about covers it for
this video you know there's also my own
personal favorite explanation for UFOs
and that's that we're in a simulation
and the so-called UFOs are just the Sim
technicians coming to take a look at
things but of course we're probably not
in a simulation I hope you've enjoyed my
big alien Halloween special
thanks for watching guys make sure you
like And subscribe for more
Gamba goji
mibihoba
repto shiglottaba
mimiwa
gambled off
bamborghi oh
no just make them piss himself
take away all of his friends
oh hey organism you still love playing
Sims oh it's you yeah I've been playing
it for hours now oh Mommy I just don't
see what you see in that game well I
don't see what you see oh this character
huh
what a weird looking guy
make him get abducted again that was
cool it's really compelling torturing
this guy anyway I'm going to bed
yes yes right off to bed Quinn
one day I'll do this to the real you oh
stop